you mentioned last time you spent time
as a buddhist monk
we like
didn't spend much time talking about i i
just would love to talk to you about
about it a little bit more
maybe as uh by way of advice
how do you recommend people can
integrate meditation into their lives
or how does one meditate
i i think for me meditation was
um
really an active effort um
which sounds weird because most people
think of meditation as like they lack
the absence of activity
um
but just like anything uh meditation is
it requires exercise
in this case it requires exercise and
quieting your mind
and the whole
well there's a lot of different reasons
people meditate
most people watching this
podcast or this show or what is this
called i don't know is this a interview
i'm not even recording this it's just
you and i talk
it is
you know most people are
uh meditating to like bring some balance
and bring some sanity to their life and
just like be able to control their
feelings and emotions a little bit more
and for that purpose like
i think the best way to to you know what
meditation is if you can call it what
you will it's just getting some alone
times time to think or not think you
know whatever and that looks different
for each person for me
it was a very active effort to try to
quiet my mind
with the explicit intent to detach from
things
from lots of things and it's actually it
sounds weird in our culture here to talk
about detachment as a goal detachment
from loved ones detachment from objects
is kind of
easy to reconcile like people understand
that yeah i don't want to be too
attached to my car or whatever
but detachment from a loved one is like
a very hard thing because we want to do
the opposite usually we want to love a
loved one
but in
a lot of buddhist thought
it is those attachments that keep people
in this cycle of rebirth now i don't
personally um believe in rebirth in the
way that uh you know
uh
a and in a buddhist sense and that like
you actually get
born multiple times i think we my
personal feeling is we die and we're
vanished
that's just me
and
but i still really
found meditation to be extraordinarily
powerful
to
feel control over a whole different part
of my body that i never thought that
it could be controlled your mind like
you close your eyes
and most of us immediately start seeing
blotches and
we start thinking about things and
and it's an amazing feeling to start
getting to the point where you can
actually
actually quiet your mind and close
your mind down so that you can just
have peace like silence of your mind for
a long period of time and you know i
loved it it was you know but it's a it's
kind of a dangerous slope because you
can kind of get caught up in it and like
really start
going from okay i'm trying to quiet my
mind to almost being like addicted to
quieting your mind
and it was a very active exercise every
day 15 hours a day to just
practice quieting my mind
and eventually i could you know it and
and
in buddhism there's a whole lot of
stages that you go through too
once you hit that point where you can
quiet your mind then there's
like other
psychological things that happen and
eventually the the
end goal for a buddhist monk who's
spending their life meditating in the
forest
is to achieve nirvana is to have
an absence of any attachment to the
point where
you're not even attached to your own
foot or your own leg you can cut it off
and
you say well that was so you don't even
have an attachment to self like to you
to ego to cod do you feel like a
conscious being or no
like the goal never attained it but you
know is that the goal that would be so
the goal is
you have to first look at it through the
eyes of some sorta which is the cycle of
rebirth
which is suffering it's a cycle of
suffering it's how it's viewed and the
idea is like if i really love this hat
and then the hat gets lost i'm sad so
that makes me suffer
and if i hate this hat and i see it then
it makes me sad or mad and that you know
it's an emotion but if i have zero if
i'm completely ambivalent about that hat
i don't care it's there i don't care if
it gets lost if it's shredded
then that is invokes no emotional rise
out of me good or bad and so the idea is
to find the balance there where
you are so detached from everything that
you're not getting a rise negative or
positive and
you know this is really it's really such
a distinct
thing
in a relative to our normal lives here
in america where
we live for rises you know you want
happiness and joy and then you also you
know nobody wants sadness but like when
you come out of sadness you feel happy
you understand either way it averages
out right and if it doesn't average out
then you're
you know you're in a bad spot like that
would be
things like major depressive disorder
where you're truly not averaging out but
if you're
living a pretty happy life that's why
there's no right or wrong you can go up
and down and you average out or you can
just
go that straight line
this is not necessarily
the the buddhist ideal is somehow
obviously
the ideal you should strive for but the
actual access exercise and meditation
that they the buddhist monks use seems
like um
seems like a great tool
for becoming aware of your own mind
and that seems to be important for
appreciating life or some some kind of
uh experiencing life
on a deeper level
i i think so i mean that's my
my personal opinion is yes and that i
think it
i don't meditate anymore
um
back in the capitalist western world
yeah where there's meetings and
that's right i mean i stopped i i was a
monk and then the tsunami hit and i
lived in a refugee camp and i was that
was the indian ocean tsunami in 2004
and it just really
it was really interesting in sri lanka
they wanted me i asked well what can i
do to help
it was it was a horrible horrible
you know hell on earth um
experience in many ways but
when i said what can i do to help
the answer was well you could meditate
like that's how you know be it keep keep
doing what you're doing like that's how
you
that's how we can get good karma and to
me coming from like western roots
i just couldn't deal with that i i just
said that it doesn't make sense to me
why would i just sit and meditate when
there's so much devastation happening
here and and so i kind of stopped
meditating then and then never really
recovered from that time in the refugee
camp
but
i do feel like i understand or like i am
aware of of a part of me that most
people never get the privilege to be
aware of and that is a pretty profound
and
it's a it's a profound uh feeling i
think or just awareness to to say i do
have the if i ever need to go back to
that i have the capacity
to do that and i do use it i mean
i don't use it a lot
but i use it when i really need to um
to try to like settle to settle myself
to
to actually calm
myself whether it's pain physical or
emotional pain like it is possible to
make those things go away but it just
like anything it takes training
[Music]
have you if you take yourself back to
that place you were
you know sam harris talks about
that uh through his meditation practice
he's able to
escape the sense of free will
and uh this the sense of agency
you can get away from that hey do you
ever think about consciousness and free
will
when when you were meditating like did
you get some deep insight about the
nature
of consciousness
that you are somehow able to escape it
through meditation or no
i looked at it in a much more
utilitarian way i think and
the sensation like minimizing amount of
thoughts in your mind and then beginning
to really appreciate the sensation
yeah you weren't writing a book on the
on free will right
and uh i mean maybe if i kept at it you
know
there's a good chance that if the
tsunami didn't happen i might still be
sitting there on the top of that
mountain uh because tsunamis you see uh
pain you see especially um
uh if you see cruelty and you're
supposed to meditate through that that
doesn't
there's something in the human spirit
that pushes us to want to help
if you see somebody who's suffering
to react to that seems like to help them
as opposed to
care less through meditation
don't become attached to the suffering
of others
exactly i mean that's i i do think that
that's you know and they're two totally
valid ways to live life yeah um they are
generally i think they're ingrained in
us pretty early in society right and
it's hard to escape
you